in this box is a sample of what they
believe to be the first live uh omicron
variant of covid19 it's just arrived
here at the center for virus research in
glasgow the reason i'm wearing all of
this protective equipment the scientists
working here are as well this is allowed
for handling live viruses
the fact they've got
a live sample is really significant when
pcr tests get done normally the virus is
inactivated and is dead so all the
positive cases of omicron we've had so
far haven't been any use to researchers
here so this has been delivered
specifically by public health scotland
to get them started and answering those
urgent questions
that we need answered about omicron
now they've got the sample they can grow
it up infect human cells with it in this
laboratory and once they've grown the
virus up to sufficient quantities of
enough
virus to be able to split up and do
these experiments the first one really
they want to do is to establish
is it going to be
resistant to the vaccine to the
antibodies we have
produced by vaccines is it going to
avoid the vaccines that we have in a
vaccinated population like uk that's a
really crucial question and they can
start to answer it here other
experiments they can do is to see is it
more infectious than previous variants
of kobit 19
so far the delta variant the one that's
dominant now around the world is by far
the most infectious variant we've seen
if omicron proved to be more infectious
that'd be a problem if it's less
infectious it's unlikely to become
dominant so that's another crucial
question and finally they can perhaps
address or get some hints at least is it
more deadly is it more pathogenic than
other strains of covid that have come so
far
but it's important to say these
experiments will take time it's going to
take several days just to isolate the
virus it's going to take
several weeks to get all of those
experiments done to answer those
questions but it is urgent that they're
done because we need to know how to
tailor our public health response in the
face of this new variant